honestly this this is really well
written I just I don't feel like I want
to do the Wednesday dance for promo
because we've seen so much of that
already and I think it's time to do
something new
um yeah you know yes yes yes yes we
didn't want to do the dance either so
that dance
[Music]
yeah you know the one from Netflix's hit
series Wednesday
[Music]
the dance did you know that it would go
viral crazy viral no
because it was kind of some of
The Improv turned into a full-blown
phenomenon yeah I appreciate everyone
wearing the black but that doesn't mean
Jenna Ortega wants to bust a move for
her SNL hosting debut we didn't want to
do the dance either so oh okay I just
didn't know because you're all dressed
exactly like Wednesday are we
the scream star teases her first time
tackling the Live sketch show with help
from SNL's comedy Trio please don't
destroy is this from your television
program yeah down to the thrill what are
you talking about I'm nervous but
excited at the same time just because
I've been a fan of the show for such a
long time and it wouldn't be a dream
come true for us to do the dance with
you so let's just not do it then I I
barely know it
okay fine
are you being serious yeah
I'm excited to be in front of an
audience I feel like you yeah learn so
much when you do theater stuff like that
so that'll be a nice change of pace the
fact that anybody has done anything
about appreciation or have even tried it
themselves is kind of um it's not
fathomable to me
[Music]
Camila Cabello and Lady Gaga just two of
the many a-listers who came down with a
case of Wednesday fever
[Music]
and then
you go down the tick tock rabbit hole
and look at all the people doing it no I
can't be on Tick Tock I can't I can't
look into all of that stuff Wednesday
Adams more like Thursday Jones hey I
don't even know what that is like I
could say to you like why are you
dressed like a reporter from the 70s
funniest yeah expect plenty of laughs
from the 20 year old when she takes the
stage in studio 8h
we've got a lore him in
we execute them but in the same weekend
Jenna's slashing into theaters with
Scream Six you got a problem here guy
ah
I'm so excited to see her on SNL I've
never really done sketch comedy like
that before and um I think it'll be
really quick Pace perfect I think we got
it guys but you put all that stuff on
just to film it
damn it
[Music]
foreign